the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to explain you who
has your high is and which character it
could be in TV show okay
I am very that most of you watched only
TV show but a lot of you didn't read the
book
so for all of you and of course for all
of you that are not introduced with azor
Ahai and his legendary story let me
first tell a little bit about azor Ahai
and then I'll focus on rebirth of azor
Ahai and which character it might be
azor Ahai was alleged their hero who
will did a burning sword called light
bringer in some other cultures this
warrior is called haiku no the hero in
tar etherion and eldritch shadow chaser
legend of light bringer says that the
darkness laid over the world and the
hero azor Ahai was chosen to fight
against it but to fight the darkness is
real hi needed to forge a sword
Asura High's first attempt to forge a
sword last thirty days and 30 nights
until it was done but when he went to
tempering in the water the sward cracked
after death through height right again
by that time it took him 50 days and 59
to make the sward to temper this time a
high capture the line and stick the
sward in the lion's heart but once again
the sward cracked azor Ahai knew that he
must forge sward the matter of
consequences so he tried one more time
one more time in which he gave all of
his effort and in which he sacrificed
his beloved wife this third time has
rawhide worked 400 days and 100 nights
until it was finished and this time
Zurich all for his wife needs an inside
ask her to bare her breasts as rohi
stroked his Forge sward into his blood
via slimming heart her soul combining
with the steel of the sward creating
Lightbringer the red sward of heroes it
is unknown if azor Ahai is connected
with the legend of the last hero who
lived during the long night and helped
to defeat the others however according
to prophecy in ancient books of a shy
from over 5,000 years ago azor Ahai will
be reborn again will be reborn when an
evil cold darkness descends upon the
world
it's said that wielding light bringer
once again azor Ahai will stand against
the others and if he fails to rule fail
sweating
according to prophecy these are
indicators of the coming of sir hi let's
start with those indicators after long
summer when the Stars glean and the cold
breath of darkness falls heavy on the
world he azor Ahai she'll be born again
amid smoke and sold he shall wake
dragons out of stone he shall draw from
the fire burning sword Lightbringer
if azor Ahai is the same as the prince
that was promised he she is born of the
line of aries ii and rowella also he
she's the Song of Ice and Fire
according to rag or Targaryen on the TV
show first time we met with azor Ahai
his theory was the scene in which
Stannis welds a magic sword that was
forged by plunging a blade through the
burning statue of the maid and a set of
Dragonstone
Alton well Sandra kuma Stannis that he
is azor Ahai that ceremony was meant to
be Roberto fuzzer hai the burning
statues of the seven provided smoke at
the waves on the shores of Dragonstone
provided assault but however Stannis
wasn't born from the line of Medeiros
and Rolla and also while Stannis Wars
shine thanks to Melisandre is Magic it
gave off no heat meaning a sward could
impossible be Lightbringer
now let's monitor in which Jon Snow is
azor Ahai let's start with possible
proofs they're going in favor to this
theory after long summer azor Ahai will
be reborn ahmed smoke and sold prophecy
says this would point on jon
resurrection he was reborn after he was
stabbed to death by Knights which
traders so here we have rebirth but what
about the part of smoke and salt in it
well in my opinion the wall could
represent the soul since in the books
it's told that the wall contains the
salt in it quoting from the books the
doors up early brushed against the top
or bronze head and drop of water fell on
him and ran slowly down his nose it was
strangely warm and salty as a tear now
this sentence confirms the fact that the
wall is salty but could the salt of the
world present salt in sentence of
prophecy well in my opinion it could now
let's try sold smoked part in it since
the prophecy says that as ur high will
be removed amid smoke and salt
well the smoked part also came true do
you remember the notes Andrea Vahl she
performed resurrections ritual to bring
John
life to remember the Mulsanne jacquard
lakhs of John's hair and thought the
curls into the flames after which we've
seen the smoke this is the only one part
of prophecy but this is not the only one
part that matches with prophecy it said
that princesses promised should have the
blood of the Dragon should be born of
the line of the Mad King Aerys Targaryen
and relative garyun with John is if
Ragnar truly is his father let's assume
that HBO didn't trick us once again and
let's assume that there are no more
secrets let's assume that rageh really
is John's father in that case John is
born of a line of Aris and Rolla
furthermore they are John's grandfather
and grandmother also in the TV show
adaptation whose showrunners snow from
Georgia remarking himself whose real
high is they revealed in 10th episode of
season six that lyanna stark's John's
mother and the John was born under a
bleeding star which fulfills the part of
prophecy which says that the prince that
was promised will be born under a
bleeding star as you could see Heather
Stark entered the Tower of joy with the
blooded sword on the ancestral sward
which was forged from a fallen star does
Don covered in blood counts yeah I think
it does it's also important to highlight
a few other facts like for example
Vanilla's Andre looks into the fire to
see azor Ahai but Sandra only sees
things related to either John or snow
second thing that I would highlight is
John's dream that he dreamy in the books
the dream in which he fights the other
say Cade White Walkers with a red sward
burning in his hand the only thing that
John didn't achieve at least not yet is
awakening dragons from stone I don't
know if all of this is only coincidence
or Johnny's really Ezra high and the
promised prince but in my opinion there
is also possibility and proves of azor
Ahai being female instead of male the
prophecy was originally made using the
villain word for dragons
or neither male or female meaning that
azor Ahai may be reborn as a female as
well let's see if the nurse has more
matches to be as your high let's focus
on possible proof that Daenerys is azor
Ahai the prophecy fits the nurse
perfectly she was born at Dragonstone an
island in the Narrow Sea
meaning that we have sold from base
hitting the shores of Dragonstone and
also she was reborn
as the mother of dragons son Khal
Drogo's burning funeral bonfire which
matches for the part of prophecy which
includes amid smoke on that bonfire
dense tree dragon eggs hatched which
fits perfectly in part the prophecy
which says born amidst salt and smoke to
wake dragons from stone also very
important fact is that on the morning
for the first time the red comet appear
in the sky which fades the part which
says when the stars bleed for the final
confirmation of the nares being azor
Ahai we have an additional prophecy from
a roots of which prophesied that the
prince that was promised would be born
from the line of Aries and relah as we
all know this prophecy also fits the
nearest perfectly since the nurses
daughter of Aries and relah when Samwell
Tarly told to mainstream on the rumors
about the nearest Targaryen and her
dragons Amon became certain that
Daenerys is prophesied leader a month
old Sam no one ever looked for a girl it
was a prince that was promised not a
princess and also told Santa Daenerys is
the one born amidst salt and smoke the
Dragons Prewitt a month old in maester
aemon spirit life he thought Rhaegar was
the prince that was promised as Ryoga
was born during the tragedy at summer ho
I mean smoke of the burning castle but
it's all coming from the tears of those
who cried for those who had died by that
time maester aemon was wrong in this
video I Buddha's were high in the prince
that was promised as the one same person
but what if those two are not going to
be one person no matter on similarities
almost the same prophecies about this -
what if azor Ahai is the one hero while
the prince that was promised is another
one could it be that one hero is going
to be Jon Snow while the other one is
going to be Daenerys Targaryen and those
two together will fight against the
darkness against the White Walkers now
I'm going to tell you one fan theory at
Orion with Jorah Mormont is azor Ahai by
this theory the soul prepares to the sea
which is as we know salty deceiver Jorah
got greyscale where the smoke refers to
what his arm becomes again this is only
a fun theory so don't take it too
seriously as the theory goes the part of
prophecy which says awakening dragons
from stone is by this theory fulfilled
the fact that you are protected dragon
eggs from his Aries and by that Jory is
credible four eggs being hatched by this
theory jor-el figure out that Daenerys
is too obsessed with becoming Queen and
with avenging her family while John eats
her armies and dragons to support great
war in the north in this theory george
RR martin along with Dan and Dave tried
to convince us that juror would never
betray Daenerys but eventually he will
apparently Jory is going to realize that
White Walkers must be stopped and the
only way to gain Danny's army and
support is to do unimaginable to kill
the nearest in favor to save Westeros
from the long night I have to admit that
in this theory it represent perfect
parallel to our highsec rifice in his
beloved wife Nissa Nissa
and it will represent bittersweet ending
that george RR martin earlier announced
as the theory goes George stabs an
heiress to the heart giving to his ward
then his magical dragon blood which will
make his fort burning this theory
affirms the Danny will become a villain
John is the last hero while Joe is azor
Ahai as I've said this theory is only
for fun there are a lot of things that
don't match we prophesy about it so
don't take this theory too seriously I
mean lying on John being as you're high
all the nurses the princess that was
promised just like maester aemon said
what's your opinion on all of this do
you think that azor Ahai and the
princess that was promised are the same
hero or do you think it's two different
heroes let me know your opinion in the
comment section down below hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and yeah see you next time peace
[Music]